[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and you're
watching "The Developer Show."
And we're doing another
episode of Google I/O 2016.
Right now we're about to take
a look at the Firebase Sandbox
booth.
And I'm here with Magnus.
Hi, Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hey!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
All right, Magnus.
Let's take a look at what's
inside the Firebase booth.
First of all is the Firebase
Test Lab for Android.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This
is an actual rack
as it looks like
in the data center.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Yes, that's correct.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
I want to hug it.
You want to hug it?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: It's amazing.
The thing with this thing
is you can feel the heat
from these devices as they are
testing different apps right
here at Google I/O.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It's really cool.
I mean, I knew, conceptually,
that there was going
to be a rack full of devices.
But it's literally a
rack full of devices.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah,
it's quite amazing.
I mean, a rack like
this, you would typically
see just rack computers
stuffed in here.
But here, you see real devices.
And if you zoom
into the screens,
you can actually see the apps
being tested by these robots.
I mean, it's amazing.
People or companies, they have
sometimes hundreds of devices
that they have on a device
[INAUDIBLE] in order
to test their apps.
With this type of
technology, all of that
can go away,
because you can test
all of that stuff in
the cloud and stuff.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
And all you do is you
head over to the console--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
upload your app.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You
make a few clicks,
and then it just
goes off and running.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Correct.
It's amazing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Magnus, this is beautiful.
And I know it's data.
Help me understand
it a little more.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So what we did
is that we took real analytics
data from Firebase Analytics.
And then we created this arty
LED representation of it.
So what you see in these
LEDs being lightened up
is actually real data
from Firebase Analytics,
from the Bingo Blast app.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
it's beautiful, too.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah, it is.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
it's a great way
to start a
conversation about data
and take it to the console.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So here you
can see the Firebase Analytics
dashboard.
You can see the number
of active users.
They're going up or down.
The average revenue per user.
How many of them have first
opened the application.
So see the growth you have in
terms of application usage.
Their engagement.
How much in-app
purchases they have done.
It's just amazing.
You have all this
data available right
there in the Firebase
Analytics dashboard.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's very cool.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
You can scroll down
here, and you can even
get more information-- the
app version that's out there,
the different device
models being used,
and also the location
in the world.
And also, if I go
down here, you can
see the country, the region,
the demographics of the users,
and what they're interested in.
It's absolutely amazing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And one of
the things they talked about
in the overview talk
and in the keynote
is audiences, and
being able to segment
by different demographics.
Can you show us that?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
So you can go in and you
can select Audiences here.
So if anyone did
a purchase which
was larger than $10
from the country is BR,
then we want to
target that audience.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very good.
Let's take a look
at one more thing,
and I think this is one of the
highlights of all of Google
I/O, which is foosball.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Here's
foosball, and this is Ali.
We found him.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Yeah, we did. [LAUGHS]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Ali, you
built this amazing thing
with some other DevRel folks.
Tell us about it.
ALI AFSHAR: So it's a
foosball table, essentially.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: (LAUGHING) Yeah.
ALI AFSHAR: When you
play a game of foosball,
when one team scores,
they press their button.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
ALI AFSHAR: And that offlays
the score on the table,
and it puts a request to
Firebase Database, which
I know you know all about.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
And we have triggers
on that data that then
run and update the score,
so that we have the High
Score table over that
and the little
lights on the table
to replace the
abacus-like features
on the standard foosball table.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
should we play a game?
ALI AFSHAR: Sure.
We could watch those.
I don't want to
embarrass you too much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh.
I think you will
embarrass me, but I
think everybody wants
to see that happen.
So let's grab the next game.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Your
honor, Your Honor.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, so
that's Firebase foosball.
I wouldn't say a fair match,
but certainly a decisive one.
Thanks for joining
us for this clip.
Check out all the links below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]